want to read a book A Week even if
you're busy here's the secret it's not
about reading faster or finding more
time it's about creating a system that
makes reading
inevitable think about this the average
person spends 3 hours a day watching
Netflix enough time to read War and
Peace three times a month yet we tell
ourselves we don't have time to read
here's the game changer the 30 page
solution read just 30 pages a day and
you'll finish a book every eight days
but the real power isn't in the math
it's in the psychology break it down 10
pages with your morning coffee five
pages during lunch and 15 pages before
bed suddenly 30 pages isn't just
achievable it's
automatic and here's the kicker your
environment is making decisions for you
every day place your book on your
nightstand open to your bookmark and put
your phone charger in another room
you've just made reading the path of
least resistance ready to trans form
your reading habits watch the full video
and discover how to build a reading
system so natural you'll wonder why you
didn't start sooner